en français on dit maths avant que quelque chose
de malheureux n'arrive non c'est censé
souhaiter ce livre comment tu as dit maths et
c'est pas de chance de répondre merci oh
ouais bien sûr d'accord
pourquoi y a t'il de la musique dans mon casque
parce que tu as besoin de te détendre avant  sortir
ça peut être trop distrayant
hey rose ce n'est pas la première fois pour
moi je sais ce que je fais bien je vais
te ramener le cul ici je
me souviens une fois que tu es dans l'espace ton
cerveau deviendra confus en voyant la
terre  sans ressentir aucune gravité ça va
commencer à paniquer
d'accord d'accord tu es prêt prêt
là oh mon dieu donne moi le PGT s'il te plait ouais je l'
ai
juste un jour de plus et nous sommes là hé
reviens bien je suis peut-être amoureux
de l'espace mais je  je suis plus amoureux de ma
femme et mes enfants me manquent terriblement voir
la seule chose qui me fait peur ici
quoi donc je suis heureux pour eux alors maintenant je peux
faire ouais tu dois le pousser vers le bas
puis le tirer d'accord et toi  qu'est-ce
qui t'attend un gentil euh personne qu'est-ce que
tu veux dire personne eh bien disons
que j'ai toujours voulu aller dans l'espace
parce qu'il n'y a rien de spécial qui
me retient là-bas pousse-le vers la gauche
ok en fait si je ne devais jamais revenir
à la Terre ça ne m'a pas dérangé
nous avons quelques problèmes de communication
enregistrez le silence radio pendant quelques minutes
revenez vers nous
quel est le problème Eva - nous ne
savons pas vraiment très
bien cette étape ça fait 30 minutes maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'ils font en train de prendre  attention à l'
adaptateur oh d'accord
oh-ho-ho d'accord super d'accord j'ai besoin d'aide
pour revenir non non je vais bien je vais juste
me tirer le long de l'attache d'accord
ici pour même un tout va bien là-bas
ouais je '  m bon tout va bien merci
crapaud ouais qu'est ce que la musique distrait tu tais
tu confirmes qu'il faut huit
tours pour enlever la plaque positive
haters ici on a pu restaurer la
reconnaissance mais il se passe quelque chose
qu'on ne peut pas expliquer mais en mal  ici,
nous ne vous recevons pas au-dessus de Houston,
vous avez été coupé, est-ce que vous
obtenez quelque chose dans l'ISS maléfique
pour rien, nous n'avons rien, toutes
les communications sont interrompues, même avec les
stations au sol, il n'y a rien, nous
revenons au début  ligne et nous pouvons
continuer sans la supervision nous avons frappé l'
air amour prêt avez-vous compris ce que j'ai
reçu un message la qualité était trop
mauvaise pour que je comprenne tout mais
je pense que cela venait de Houston
c'est des conneries ne peut pas entendre un message
sans nous ici à toutes
les communications sont coupées de notre côté
j'essaie de contacter d'
accord avec ça dans le style anaérobies tu
dois vraiment y aller Jane nous revenons
oh hé chérie eh bien nous ne pouvons pas partir si nous
peut communiquer avec Houston comprendre
nous allons le comprendre
oh arrêtez ce que vous faites obtenez les outils
et rejoignez-moi dans la capsule Jane s'il
y a un signal de nous dites-nous d'accord
dès que je suis ici retirez mon DMC nous  allons
vérifier les transmissions et nous partons
Rose dépêchez-vous qu'est-ce que tu fais est-ce que
ça aide
maintenant nous allons nous rattraper ici alors Jane
je veux dire Ella Rose nous t'attendons
même un pour Eva pour te faire copier
oui qu'est-ce que tu es  fais reviens ici
je vais rester ici eh bien ce n'est pas le
moment de plaisanter
oh je ne veux pas devenir méchant qu'est ce que
tu fais tu as un
ami de la famille tu as une vie qu'est ce qui ne va pas avec
toi donne moi dix secondes quoi  ça arrive
ma mère je ne peux pas y retourner
oh nous n'avons pas le temps de faire ça
je ne peux pas te laisser juste aller nous avons -
allez Rose ne sois pas stupide je m'arrête
tu me dis si j'ai  à
Rose tu ne vas pas me faire changer d'
avis allons
y il
éclot une chaîne fermée
elle ne vient pas
mon truc de ceinture de sécurité dans l'espace
[Musique]
Oh
toi